[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
d'ailleurs c'est pas mes chiens ce sont
des chiens les chiens qui habitent chez
nous je les considère comme mes
colocataires donc mes chiens payer un
loyer ok mes chiens s'occupent eux-mêmes
de leur nourriture ni ramassent
mes chiens sont libres ok mes chiens
font exactement ce qu'ils veulent
alors tout d'abord je tiens à dire qu'on
ne
représente les Caleb parce que si
on représente on aurait toujours 5
% dans les dans les dans les experts
pardon de dire ça comme ça mais on
essaie de représenter la France qu'on
voudrait qu'elle soit il se nourriss il
y en a qui vont à l'épicerie il y en a
qui chassent par eux-mêmes moi ça fait à
peu près 14 ans que j'ai jamais fait
l'épicerie n'est-ce pas les chiens quand
même qui mangent à table puis toi qui
mange les miettes à terre
on mange tous à terre